to be honest I don't know if I'm gonna
make it through the whole thing but I'm
gonna try my best not feeling a hundred
percent I have I've rebel the gold label
it has apparently some nice stuff in it
let me give some shoutouts frozen milk
or bronze bronze milk I read it as
brozen like rosin okay it's uh it's time
to focus rather ban okay
I'm currently at my all-time highest
bully rating so this might not last but
we'll see let's play a London
it's focus yeah chat you'll have to talk
amongst yourselves I already messed up
the opening Bishop ISA it's interesting
no this is a good line it's not too bad
though once running Bishop takes d4
thanks for subbing appreciate it
I just want to trade simplify your
rookie one you founds a bit tender hmm
and before is coming play this move
[Music]
hmm okay you live with this oh I miss
something
no it's okay it's a little bit dirty but
got it done yeah I didn't want to lose
the reading there okay playing another
strong player
thanks for the bits raw meat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hopefully g5o that traps my queen let's
be safe I'm trying I'm trying trying hmm
take this wanna play us for
I'm not flagging will be difficult to do
[Music]
it was terrible
yeah I was so slow that game man
I didn't recover from the previous game
I'm not tilted I'm just not feeling well
playing Vova chess okay
I played Vova a chest before I'll just
stick with London
never mind I'll play this month Bishop
g5 it's the line that sticks no I pass
left oh okay it's not that bad I don't
think maybe it is bad work me woman
coming let's play f4 again a bit of a
mess that six is interesting how that
pawns are marching Queen g5 Queen takes
c3 I mean it might be mating but it
might not be a Knights you think you
wanna thank you one for Oh queen h3
should not have taken so much title it's
so close to mate
[Music]
no I was really bad I was really was I'm
not moving fast enough earlier on yeah
okay so hopefully I can recover here I
need I need some source of speed and
confidence
don't be six I'll play to this move and
that comes to c4
that's some kind of attack on the
kingside the e4 in Queen b6 expected
yeah I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying to
be confident bits don't hurt let's play
this the d6 is attacked Queens attacked
hmm bring the Knight to g4 take let's
play this move not sure what I'm doing
here just have to play quicker it's a
great position shouldn't complain up on
time now you got this I'm trying yeah I
think I got this game lead school was
that tog II know someone
I think someone I'm Bishop before I free
Queen not free Queen f6 BAM attacking
the rook oh that didn't work let's just
play this okay thank you Garo 27x thinks
everyone else
gnorm strong okay so I'm 50%
hey I'm twenty hundred on the dot
Peaceful Warrior
that's scary name let's play this
opening again
Bishop e2 let's reverse Halloween now
this is all just terrible for me so many
regrets Bishop g5 destroys me my Queens
just trapped oh okay
I'm still doing the fights because pawns
hanging 92 though this is really bad
that's why you don't play Halloween
against good players it's a confusing
move the rocks are fort I'm gonna win
the night
never mind please player okay please
[Music]
one check just meets me once hesitating
it's pleased to Ono f3 I'm so close to
hang still needed clothes a terrible
game and okay let's try and be a better
influence for the younger generation 146
I've been playing some good players
though yeah I have not label it in like
a few weeks at least consistently okay
let's play some opening it's 56 now I'm
just going for simple chess I see four
maybe six is useful I take I think I can
take okay so I'm up upon
[Music]
let me play this move it'll just take
it's a great position I'm low on time
ooh this is okay thanks for the bits I
think I was aware of that but thank you
I didn't celebrates I had the chance
[Music]
Lucas trapped oh it's not trapped Wow
without seeking some moves
Wow Wow
it was a weird sequence look at that
sequence this is this is top level play
right here
rook d2 be for rook takes D 3 C 3 rip d2
or the promove okay look terribleness
okay let's try and calm down I just want
to play like a solid game or I'm up on
time the whole time and where I don't
have to like stress so far so good
please checkmate hmm not sure who should
be more scared my king is actually kind
of safe after an IP 3
I was a weird move the Queen can't take
because I take here it takes here I
think I take here
upon time at least hmm now I just want
to meet doc wants to meet me hey fair
enough too scary move ha oh that was a
great position to something like
terribly wrong
I wanted to play Queen h8 here if it
doesn't work have lockout initiative
what to do I'm below my peak now which
means I could peak again
hey main mystery chess no one knows
ok I'm just gonna stick with my main
repertory
Bishop c4 this looks Pleasant this pawn
is hard to win and the pawn and kind of
restricts these pawns removing yes oh
I'm happy to take and the square is very
nice I'm gonna be a little bit greedy
and greedy here when another pawn
shining Knight b6 that's a good move I
[Music]
might be threatening to take I don't
know let's be safe now I'm trying to
take get up a ton of time yeah I just
want to simplify
[Music]
what to do I'm just gonna move around
for 30 more seconds or however long so
that was a bad meal of okay time is good
not the most impressive chest I'm up to
Ponce okay
let's go let's go I want a game I think
the goal is to break into top 100 also
shout out to weeb and shout out to
milesg thanks for thanks for subbing for
six months half a year dr. estranged not
the scariest doctor Oh Carlson's playing
I don't think I acknowledge that and
Carlson's in the tournament so the goal
is to play Carlson Abby finds a great
great move for bullets okay that's
Pleasant
it ponds are the tender but it's
defended wow that's a great move you
have this move it's unclear now I think
everything's defended ooh rook see one
could hurt me please five I'm losing a
piece here unless I'm not I'm not a 5mm
in this move counter-attack but the
bishops gonna hang an end
oh wow okay white luck me off the hook
oh but there's 97 so I'm losing the
exchange oh look I have to take with
Queen cos f8 issues was crazy move oh
that was a terrible move by honey 5 what
do I do here I just have to survive and
then maybe dirty flag that's so bad
good move what self still means or self
checkmate dah
[Music]
I got into trouble the opening was good
but like a compensation Gabriel numbers
thanks for subbing yeah Carlson
Carlson's playing I think he's playing
the title Verena yeah has not won a
title arena in in a while I think that's
play grass over here it spawns hanging
ok but I'm getting comp d4 is even d3 d3
is interesting hmm might be regretting
my decision you're taken to this move
Bishop g4 it's all about initiative
I'm trying to get something here I just
want to like play this move I'll play
this H for coming I have a time
advantage it's still down to pawns
I'll hide t3 hmm oh I have this move the
sensing tactics that's nice it's torture
wait yes I win the Queen and the rook
and then I'll win more stuff okay let's
go
I found a tactic oh so weird game a lot
of catching up to you I have no streak I
keep winning and losing like back and
forth I have not had a streak yet this
tournament I've not won my only streak
was two losses in a row I've not won two
games in a row let's change that here
sure players focus and consistency this
is supposed to just be good for whites
[Music]
that was a free pond another free pong
should be six come in let's defend
defense more attack
on the play bishops III you take off
seven takes there to be a little bit
careful let's just treat Queens or win a
free quickie house nice it's my first
double win maybe let's go let's go
momentum let's feel some height yeah at
the beginning of the tournament I said I
might not play the whole thing and it
still remains true but I'm feeling some
energy at least buzzer thanks for
subbing oh I'm playing a Stena strong
player let's play a London all right
whatever this is
oh the same opening everyone playing
this okay 25 is a better move or is it
can I just take Bishop c4 is useful
before a lot can play this
all the pawns are falling blacks getting
some comp
hmm let's be safe
[Music]
I'm losing some pawns back unfortunately
if this move does win something attack
the Queen Knights defended
that was a free for your rook that's
nice
no I flagged oh no oh no oh that's so
unfortunate that's really tilting cuz I
was I just winning and then I flocked I
was looking for this Lake there's a
fancy meet I forgot it was so long time
mr. sir thanks for something oh that's
so sad thanks dude
I hope you're still being instructed I
hope you're learning from my mistakes
that makes any sense
clay five only five
oh I resign I don't want to play that
hey Mouse slipped I meant to play rook
takes e5 oh that's so sad PD Potok
thanks for subbing ok I think that had
to do something with tilts maybe not
sure okay
let's play aggressive thing
hmm
yeah so off the side castling oh it's my
bishop t4 I won't play f5 it opens a
diagonal but I want to open up lines on
the Kings side as well taking h3 did
this move because if f5 I have a queen
e5 check which actually leads to mates
keep the attention another sub lv n 2k
welcome back for five months ok so I
cleared some squares this looks very
pleasant 25 work h3 it's close just move
back be patience the bishop is so sad
which makes me so happy let's keep the
Queen
the bishop here
no oh no no oh that was a second mal
slip oh that's so bad I should just
retire I should retire straw full time I
was so bad I'm not a mouse lipped well
white just hung a rug and I'm also Queen
b6
Oh know what to do wait and watch
Carlson twitch chat tell me what to do
here's my here's my straw poll you want
me to keep playing you don't want to see
Carlson 40 the link is in the chat if
you want to vote okay I'll call keep
playing I'll listen to the audience
Oh Carlson's creeping up oh well wait
until it gets to like 100 votes maybe
again it's in the chat okay it's still I
think enough people have spoken
it's very close oh wow
I'll keep playing yeah thanks for voting
I'll try and reclaim my oh I lost I've
lost about 40 points this tournament so
far and that was the worst possible now
slip thanks for saving that moment in
history okay at least I'm playing
someone low rated maybe I can beat
haven't had a single staffer gambit
everyone's playing like c3 okay finally
Stafford yeah at a time let's go let's
have some fun
just want to win quickly oh yeah this is
so much fun this is so much fun okay
this is a nice position queenie one just
gets me to think maybe it doesn't us
because there's Bishop takes g4
but this is this is still a lot of fun
if I'm fighting me
g3 I just take and mate
and 92 probably just takes
oh there's a funny Queen sack watch this
oh it's not happening I was ready to
like play Bishop f3 and responsive bit
of III
I still like complete domination
ooh my rooks got Forks Wow let's not
lose this and the position is still good
they Bishop g2 first oh that was nice
okay finally opponent Mouse slippery
moves something
yeah let's not stalemate okay all right
let's go
oh the polls very close it's 47% 53%
have to compromise at some points maybe
I'll keep playing until I lose or until
I get like unbearably tilted
I think I just want to win the bishop
pair yeah and then visibly 595
I'm the smooth
we're getting some structure
a five might be coming play this move as
if takes I'll take with pawn preventing
a five it's interesting
okay defending a pawn let's defend the
plants and more play c4
down a lot of time that's a free pawn
[Music]
I wanna win this pawn
know what I wanted I really not what
they wanted
[Music]
that's the trick I was a very nice trick
let's go that was a cool trick well I
was losing at some point but the time
was relevant okay I want another game so
now I'm I lost so many games I'm playing
I'm not playing like that 2807 more
which is nice I play the structure hey
thanks for summing scorpy though
Scorpio Borg
another sub work
thanks for summing the Queen belongs on
each three and maybe g4g five
okay so I'm winning a pawn g5 still
coming it's still effective
looks passive but solid
now g5i wanna trade rooks
everything's defended
oh that was a good move nice tactic this
is bad this is really bad
oh I was a good position that's
something like wrong I only have 16
points like I have not gone on the four
points victory for escape is it time to
watch Carlsen I start a new game
okay next game I lose I finish and I
watch a Harrison how about that this is
actually some fun opening theory
[Music]
let's just move back a lights already in
trouble there's a queen and rook our
alliance I think I can just play this my
knight gets trapped in envelope with a
pawn
like 93 I miss pawns weak
okay so I'm up two pawns rook belongs
here I still up two pawns put the rook
on us five never mind okay now it's
simple mmm okay your vote counts as two
points because you sucked okay this
should not be too difficult to win five
just have to slowly gradually walk up
make sure the kingdom sheltered
okay so yeah this is a plan next game I
lose then all quit and I'll watch
Carlson that's a decent compromise I
kind of recovered from tilts kind of
can't be one blocks not threatening e5
maybe now luck is this move sometimes
the best defense is offense listen each
for it's looking scary for black oh this
is a queen drop I think that was nice it
was really nice
[Music]
okay it was a good opening hey top 150
let's go
a lot of people going into this c5 I
think again I'll just take maybe the
smooth it's greedy I'm defending
everything on the play before just
putting the question this might be a
legal move that could actually do damage
which I do I take before I guess 92 a
blocks taking so long
I mean this is actually quite strong and
be fine
I will take oh well played Wow
I'm in trouble now how that happened I'm
done time
oh that turns it around really quickly
got too comfortable I'm sacking a queen
- it's not what I wanted
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay the dirty flag was a terrible game
oh wow
yeah I was okay I didn't lose though I
didn't lose the determined continues for
me it's a long name oh I showed this
chap last night on stream White's like
already much worse or is white much
worse maybe it's like a fried liver type
something I just want a night but I
regained the night I don't know what's
going on
let's take here
so now everything liquidated a five
never mind
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was good that was really good
let's go
Wow a little weird time scramble I don't
know what to make of that
I don't know how the fuel about those
games like I feel happy or sad or
emotionless okay let's continue
I still haven't lost oh that's like free
bishop I could have taken on c7
oh I'm winning a lot of things here this
was coming
[Music]
winning more things
[Music]
the game no Queen up okay so Queen f3 it
looks like a dirty trick it's actually
the best move it's new theory and yeah a
lot of players haven't discovered it yet
so but ask like stockfish early line
they'll they'll scream queen f3 okay
Mehran hey it's donation thanks graph
something something I'll look to see
what that says oh the Christmas postcard
from Poland's right yeah I I mentioned
that a few times on stream a couple
months ago I could show it it's hanging
on the fridge I just want to meet again
once I lose I'm watching Carlson to
enjoy playing while it lasts
Brooke made this my first really not
sure what to do here night belongs on f4
never mind
well the other night belongs enough for
this move preventing rugby to put the
roof on c2
interesting okay this is a nice maneuver
I'm still kind of struggling
[Music]
[Music]
nyeeehhh
okay time to watch Carlson or firoozeh
another strawpoll time okay I I withdraw
from the tournament good games thinks
people for being my opponents yeah that
was tough I had some some tragedies some
comedies but yeah my time is better
spent watching watching the best